[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q a number 36.
before we get going i think we need to
since we did not cover it in the main
podcast we need to show you a brief clip
from beirut this is
uh a spectacular event that has taken
place there this morning zach would you
put it up
[Music]
all right so there's a lot of footage of
it as a result of the
fact that there was an initial explosion
which had a lot of cameras pointed in
the direction of the billowing smoke and
then
the gigantic explosion i see indications
on twitter
that the culprit may have been 2700
tons of ammonium nitrate that had come
in on a ship into the port
and had been moved into warehouses there
so this is
very similar stuff that was used to blow
up the murrow federal building
by timothy mcveigh many years ago that
was apparently
two tons i don't understand what you
just said you you say
what you're seeing suggests that this
was an accident or intentional
well let's put it this way i believe
what we you know
early reports are always wrong and these
are still early reports
but it looks like there was a large
shipment of ammonium
nitrate that was brought into the port
for
normal purposes and uh you know
could somebody have set it off could
somebody have shipped it knowing that it
would make the port vulnerable who's to
say
but let's just say they're um the
indications so far
don't seem to suggest that they seem to
suggest a massive amount of
uh explosive material and uh
i'm sorry i'm just not tracking the the
reports so far don't seem to suggest
that it was intentional that it was
intentional okay yeah so anyway can
always change
but um anyway a terrible tragedy that
has happened there
um and it is clear
from the video that a huge number of
buildings were just simply
obliterated so how many people were in
its path is
very hard to say at this point but um
it's a certainly a very dramatic event
it makes you
wonder why anybody would allow massive
shipments
of uh materials that are this explosive
um because the danger is is obvious yeah
that's terrifying all right um on to the
q a
all right we're gonna start with three
questions from episode 35
that we did not get to and that were
interesting uh first one is
first one is there's a dog in the room
uh hi i'm a big fan what was the point
of the evolutionary process to have an
appendix why is it not an essential
organ anymore
and i wanted to pose this question
because uh it is
it is something that we have addressed
directly in our
in the first of our health and medicine
chapters in the book that we are writing
that will be out next year
so i don't know if we want to say
anything more than that right now
well i do want to say at least one thing
okay um which is
it was obvious that the story that the
appendix
was a vestigial organ of no value was
wrong right what the appendix does is a
more interesting question than that
but anyway years ago i generated a test
to counteract the argument
that in order to establish that
something was a product of adaptation
you needed to demonstrate that there was
genetic variability and that the genes
that encode the thing
out compete genes that don't this is
nonsense logically speaking
if a trait is complex
if it is expensive and if it persists
over evolutionary time
it is telling you that it is doing
something positive
for the creature and the appendix always
passed this test so i always wondered
about this
um in more recent times it has become
clear what exactly the appendix does but
the
the important part of the story there
there is a leading hypothesis
that it's you know it's not wholly
demonstrated so i don't know
i don't know that i would say that it is
i'm not so sure about that i believe it
has been
demonstrated maybe not sufficiently that
it rules out the possibility of another
interpretation
but it has withstood a substantial test
i would say
um and what what i think is most
important to realize though
is that a story that never made any
sense
and didn't match the uh
the ancestral data floated for
years on the basis that people could
remember it and it seemed
you know logical enough to people who
weren't very good at thinking
evolutionarily
and that that is a cautionary tale
because you know you can make the same
argument
for example for religion that this is a
massively expensive
phenomenon that persists over
evolutionary time and has a lot of
complexity to it
and people are still telling us that
it's a mind virus and other such
things so the belief that something is
uh expensive and persistent and not
noticed by evolution even though there's
an obvious way
to save should attract our attention and
in the case of the appendix
it's not even just the expense of the
organ which is presumably small
not negligible but small but the cost of
having
one right i know numerous people in my
direct sphere who have had an
appendicitis and presumably
most or all of them would have died from
appendicitis
if not for medical intervention and what
that says is that the fitness cost of
having such
uh a an organ is potentially very large
but here's here's the teaser so we're
not gonna we're not gonna go into the
whole story right now the teaser is
consider what about so the appendix is
part of our gi tract our
gastrointestinal tract so
consider in our gi tract is what takes
in
our our food and converts it into
nutrients that we can use
and allows us to get rid of the parts
that we can't use
so what looking at our diet would be an
interesting
a good place to start to figure out how
have our diets changed obviously
dramatically
from those of our even just
pre-industrial ancestors
that question is relevant especially in
light of the finding which probably many
people don't know
which is that the rate of appendicitis
is incredibly high among post-industrial
people that much we do know brett just
mentioned that he's known several people
with
extreme bouts of appendicitis including
your dad um
yes yes um
but uh
yeah i suppose that's true um but what
what is
what is true what is more interesting is
that pre-industrial people
have almost no rates of appendicitis so
it is this is something that has changed
in the
industrialization of our food almost
certainly and in fact what you know the
leading hypothesis for
uh what it has has changed and therefore
what the function the appendix is
is consistent with this understanding
that this is about hyper novelty of the
very modern human condition that has
turned an organ that actually was quite
important uh into one that is
apparently more of a hazard than a
benefit so
it has increased the hazard and other
features of the modern environment have
reduced the value
to near zero for modern people um so we
sure we don't want to
no we can do it okay i thought you
didn't want to so um
let's just say the leading hypothesis
is that the appendix preserves a
an isolate of the community of
microorganisms
in your gut that aid
in the extraction of nutrients from food
and
that this process means that when you
are infected by some competing uh
microorganism and your you have uh
chemical warfare going on biological
warfare going on in your gut
and you potentially lose your gut flora
to diarrhea then this isolate
that is basically in a little pouch that
sticks off of your intestine
this isolate can then repopulate your
gut very quickly
with um gut flora for which you are well
adapted
so that you can immediately go back to
extracting the nutrients from food
in a very efficient way it's your body's
probiotic source
yeah it's your body's probiotic source
maintained right where it needs to be in
a
condition where it can be preserved
through
a gastrointestinal infection
and i would just last thing is the
reason that you can eliminate it and
apparently suffer no harm
is that you have so much extra food you
don't need to be efficient at extracting
resources now it may be bad for you what
you are repopulated with
may not be very good for you in terms of
the community of microorganisms and you
may
suffer all sorts of gastrointestinal
problems that put you on things like
proton pump inhibitors that increase
your risk of covid for instance just to
go back to that
for example for example but there's also
in the modern environment no guarantee
that you're current while you're healthy
gut flora are the right ones for you
either hence these fecal transplants
that people
have so so two just two two more things
on this i mean there's this goes in a
lot of different interesting directions
but um
one of the other predictions of of what
you just said is that whereas
uh pre-industrial people who are still
alive today don't tend to have
appendicitis at all another prediction
of the model that brett just laid out is
that they will have much higher rates of
diarrhea of incidence of diarrhea
um that you know are common enough that
they don't really think about it that
much whereas
you know it's rare enough for sort of
weird you know
western educated industrialized rich
democratic uh country inhabitants
uh to have that they can go like oh yeah
that was like six months ago it was kind
of ugly right
um whereas um pre-industrial people tend
to have it more often
and the idea there is that the
repopulation of the effectively
probiotic
gut bacteria would be a more of a
regular and necessary part of
a functional gi tract for such people
who are regularly
losing all of their good bacteria
through these
to these diary incidents the other thing
is that the appendix is not just in
humans
across mammals there's a very sort of it
looks almost
chaotic if you just map the distribution
of appendix and also the cecum which is
another out pouching of the
digestive tract onto the mammalian tree
it should it's
it's it's popping on and popping off
like evolving and then
disappearing lots and lots of times um
but
it it tracks interestingly with diet
and so this is again sort of supporting
evidence that this is about
changes in diet that have rendered this
thing
not not only not useful but actually a
hazard
yes and um the
explanation that it was vestigial the
wrong explanation which we should have
spotted from the very beginning and some
of us did i mean i always knew the
appendix was going to turn out to be
useful but um
the the wrong explanation was that it
was a cecum
that was being eliminated by selection
over time
now cecum is a mechanism for
digesting cellulose it's basically a
pouch that
allows so no mammal can digest cellulose
but you can have microorganisms that do
the digesting for you in fact i think no
complex animal can digest cellulose
even termites have microorganisms i
think that's right that allow them to do
it yeah and so the point is you need a
plastic
being wood um so you need
a place for the microorganisms that can
digest cellulose so
this is so interesting cellulose is
actually the mirror image of a molecule
that we actually very easily digest but
we don't have an enzyme that deals
with the flip side and it's apparently
very what's what's the mirror image
it's uh it's um relevant here no it's a
stark
um and so those are those are cis trans
versions of
i believe so really so the um
in order to digest the cellulose you
need
microorganisms that have an evolutionary
history that allows them to digest
cellulose
you need a place for those creatures to
live so even termites have a place for
those
creatures to live in their gut and that
thing in mammals is a cecum
but the explanation that our um appendix
is
a cecum that is vestigial and therefore
receding and disappearing over time
doesn't make any sense because we don't
have the evidence for
an ancestor that digested cellulose and
needed a cecum
and so the point is you know
superficially it makes sense but it's
not
that mapped that hypothesis onto a
phylogenetic tree of our closest
relatives and
falsified like that's all you have to do
it's just it's just not a match for our
evolutionary history
yep all right
schoolyard's sing-song element to the
protest chants bothers me
have you seen this nanonan or tone
before in protests of the past
seems new to me um it's
awful and not just i mean nano nano is
right like
sing-song isn't even quite right because
it's so nasal and
off-key it's unmusical it's anti-it's
really bad now i agree it suggested
something has gone so seriously
awry um that it's just not even able to
put together
you know even the briefest of repeating
melodies and it just sounds sick
it makes you long for the complexity of
hey hey ho ho
i i find it hard to long for that
complexity having had
my name chanted hey hey how brett
weinstein's got to go
yeah um and you know i'm in fact when i
now hear that chant repurposed for other
things
i i just wonder about the noun they've
put in they wonder about the
whatever it was yeah um but yeah i do
think
this this seems particularly off-key
nasal
um yeah neener neater as a nano
yes as you say and it does it just
sounds
it sounds unwell it sounds sick yeah
the fact that you know they would
they're obviously
trying to win hearts and minds so
it would be a priority to put together
something musical and compelling and all
of that
and the inability to do it suggests just
another place
in which the people who are telling us
they know how to rebuild civilization
into a
beautiful utopia really don't know you
know they don't they don't even
recognize
those together yeah exactly okay the
final uh
one from episode 35 is more of a comment
than a question but it might be
worth us commenting on this comment the
truth is not enough
he says it is not as powerful as a lie
when it comes to reaching out because
the naked truth can be
ugly dirty and few dare to look at it
yeah um i think the ugly truth
in some contexts tends to be that or
i won't even say it tends to be there
but it tends to include that
but i don't think the truth is
inherently this way at all in fact
one of the things that i think certainly
drives me and i know
drives you in the scientific worldview
the evolutionary lens
is that you know the truth is
continually surprising and that there is
a way
that it is a series of fascinating
puzzles and i must say the truth
of race and sex and gender
and what is possible i think all of
these truths are actually a good bit
better than people imagine and that in
fact
we are we are
losing the courage of our convictions
because many people have come to fear
that the truth is so ugly
that we need to fictionalize over it and
that in fact if we were to confront the
truth
it's not all you know
sunshine and rainbows or whatever it is
but
the ultimate answer is
quite tolerable and the tragedy of us
missing
on what it would be because we are too
afraid
to go looking is it'd be hard to
overstate it first question for blast
hour
how does egg donation for assisted
reproduction affect evolutionary biology
how does it relate to concepts like
certainty of maternity
or the comment on the last stream that
all of your ancestors were successful
as there's a parenthetical here ends
with the recipient
point being that egg donation
effectively creates two mothers one of
whom is not
successful in the usual genetic standard
sense
yeah well i think very frequently we um
we lose track of the essential element
that we are
um that we should be tracking for a
given purpose so for example
when people say oh uh that's not
you know his biological child or
something like that when somebody has
been adopted
my sense is no
a father for example who raises a child
has tremendous influence in a most
biological fashion
you have to understand that culture is
biology every bit as much as genes
so it is fair to say that somebody is
not someone's genetic child
but it is wrong to say that it is not
somebody's biological child
and to say that you know
it happens we don't have any adopted
children but if
uh you know if if we did and that child
said well that's not my
uh that's not my real father right no
your real father is actually much
more the person who raised you than it
is the person who donated the genes for
one thing
the genes uh aren't all that variable in
interesting ways
what you learn from your father is
tremendously variable and so the point
is
we should be tracking the important part
in the case of
donated eggs you know you've got
from evolution's perspective it's the
genetic lineage that matters
from the perspective of the human stuff
that's actually
important right it is certainly going to
be
the person who raises the offspring and
so
the question is for what purpose right
there's also i mean
it it further splits up you know
adoption is something that's been around
for
at least thousands of years and probably
millions actually because we see
uh we see children being adopted
effectively
by um other mothers who are at the
appropriate developmental stage with
their own children in
in chimps and bonobos i believe yep um
but typically by relatives
typically by relatives yes um
if uh you know if if their mother dies
right only only under duress
um but this idea of egg donation does
does partition this even more you know
so you
you do have even more impact on a
child's development
even if it's not your genes that you
know even if you didn't
um contribute either of the gametes to
the child but if you carried that child
in in your womb for nine months that's
that's
a it's a lot of input um that's a lot of
environmental input
um that uh that you would not have
otherwise so it's
um you know so it's it's you're
impacting that child's
life um from an even earlier stage than
you do when you adopt a child
at birth yep um
it also is the case that in uh
in an implanted egg i mean for one thing
a woman can
preserve eggs and then have them
fertilized and
and reintroduced later in her life but
this also introduces a kind of
uncertainty of maternity
that's previously this is in the
question it's never been an issue for
females so
the basic answer is look this has every
impact on
the genetic thing which is what
evolution in the narrow sense
cares about it is not at all what we
should care about
and therefore there's a question of can
we track the parameters that matter
most like what sort of
human will be created how uh capable
fulfilled yeah decent will they be but i
mean we still
so much of society is still around
basically issues of certainty fraternity
whether or not people know that sure
right like people don't like to talk
about it and want to pretend it's not
true but
the fact that certainly paternity has
driven uh mating systems and social
systems and
and all civilizations uh forever uh
doesn't change just because we should be
focusing on the other stuff and so
the idea of introducing this new
uncertainty
uh this certainty of maternity um is is
a very interesting question although i
think
really except i mean i just i'm not too
familiar
with all of the sort of reproductive
assisted technologies and
and the ways that they they they get
used but
often i would think um that really you
just
you just have certainty of non-maternity
really like if you know if you
if you are a woman who can carry a child
and desperately wants a child and
um you just your eggs can't do it um you
simply know that the child that you're
carrying doesn't have your genetics but
it has
everything else you know you know you
still know you've given birth to that
child and that child is
is yours from from day one it just
doesn't happen to have your genes
so so there's you're you're flipping a
switch but you haven't actually
increased
um uncertainty any you just have gone
from
yeah i'm certain i am the genetic mother
too i'm certain i'm not
right unless you're donating eggs to
yourself but
um yeah so like so for this like
i i'm i know my eggs are good now and
i'm hoping for a moment ten years in the
future or something okay right yeah
um but you know what you have is a
mismatch between
the genetic reality about which i'm
arguing you should care very little
and the realities that matter about
which you should care in proportion to
the degree to which
they matter and i think heather's point
here which
i agree with is that it doesn't make the
stuff
that doesn't matter any less important
to the motivational structure that you
have inherited
but that motivational structure will
interface with
um the realities that you actually care
about arbitrarily so
in some sense it's the same puzzle as
for people who are young
and fertile sex is fun because of its
reproductive
potential at the point you interfere
with its reproductive potential
with birth control it is no longer
the fun does not correlate with the
increase in reproductive success that is
likely to accompany
that behavior and yet it doesn't become
less fun so
yeah um in some sense do you care that
you know that the fun was supposed to be
because you were gambling you were
playing baby roulette or
no i think that's actually maybe the
most relevant thing here because
actually since there is exactly no
history
of uncertainty of maternity in the
mammalian lineage
uh the fact that we've now introduced
uncertainty or certainty of
non-maternity
is so new that it's equivalent to
messing with the psychology with regard
to birth control which is to say it's
not insignificant but it has no
evolutionary history yeah
yeah now i should point out that
uncertainty of maternity is very
different
than just being unsure of your mom
because mom says some crazy stuff and
sometimes you just find yourself unsure
of your mom and
did zack pay you to say that i wasn't
talking about you
i was talking about you mom um all right
now we're in it okay yep
i am an adjunct teaching i'm an adjunct
teaching freshman composition
wow and you donated money to us i'm
thank you and i know how little adjuncts
make
i am an adjunct teaching freshman
composition can i see one of your
student covenants for sample language to
possibly incorporate in my own syllabus
would we sure yeah i think we would we
would share
a covenant a covenant or two maybe put
it up on
uh i have an active medium that i
haven't put anything up on a while i
i i will do that um there's a lot less
thou
shalt in it that you may be expecting
yes
yes um i was caught off guard at an
outdoor cleanup event when our
introductions required naming our
pronouns
this was a first for me clearly a sign
of my privilege has cancer degendered me
since my breasts ovaries and uterus were
removed
oh boy yeah so sorry that a community
cleanup event which should have been all
hands on deck let's do the work turned
into
an excuse for political one up
upsmanship
and uh no cancer did not degender you it
took away some of your anatomy and i'm
sorry
but that didn't change anything about
the
long developmental history and
endocrinological history
and uh you know just everything in your
development
that made you female yeah you're still
female just as much as you were um
with or without those those parts
absolutely so
um earlier you described the difference
between activation
i did organizational effects you might
just
briefly say something here oh yeah um so
there's a model in endocrinology that
is is pretty good it's probably a little
bit too simplistic but uh which is
uh speaking to the ways
that hormones affect uh the body and
development
and they're being broadly speaking two
categories activational and
organizational effects
and so uh in early development
when um testosterone gets starts getting
produced
uh for males you get a whole lot of
organizational effects of that
testosterone that
uh render the brain masculinized
and during puberty uh you get the
secondary
you don't you get not just the primary
sex characteristics but the secondary
sex characteristics
that are organizational effects of those
hormones which
require that early effect
of the testosterone but do not require
that there be ongoing testosterone once
the development of that particular thing
is over
compare that to activational effects
which basically turn on
when you've got the trigger be it
testosterone estrogen serotonin whatever
it is
and turn off when you don't have the
trigger and so
you know for instance all of this um
argument about like you know should
trans women be able to play against
women in
sports well all we have to do is make
sure their testosterone is low
no this is misunderstanding what
hormones do it's amazing imagining that
all hormonal effects are activational
as opposed to organizational and the
fact is the vast majority of hormonal
effects
in mammals are organizational that
unless you can go back in time you get a
time travel
back to fertilization and turn off all
the downstream effects of testosterone
oh and by the way there's also effects
of which chromosomes you have so that
won't even be sufficient but
absent the ability to time travel back
to day zero
you cannot simply turn on or off
testosterone and render yourself the
other sex doesn't work that way
yeah so any ambiguity at all should be
uh
neutralized by this analysis because uh
you were organized
around these things and altering things
later doesn't change it
yeah hi brett and heather greetings from
columbia
learning math helps you to learn how to
think how to solve issues how to think
outside the box
math is a tool to face and deal with and
understand nature
yes now this is from a felipe and felipe
is a relatively common name
in colombia but we when we were in the
amazon last we
met a felipe from colombia and um
he recently reached out to us and i
promptly lost into the abyss of my email
his email so i
assume that's not the same felipe but if
it is hey felipe
felipe who eats mangoes with the skin
on yeah yeah which is i mean that's
extreme mango eating is what that is
that's right
yeah um but yes to your point about math
absolutely it helps you learn how to
think it's not it's not just math or
mouth sake so you know when the kid
who's being taught by a terrible math
teacher says what is this good for when
will i ever use this
uh it trains your brain to do logic and
to do nuance
and to see pattern and to understand how
it is that you can recognize when the
pattern you think you see isn't actually
pattern but it's actually noise
that's some of what math is good for
okay so we have three questions uh
written by someone who i think's first
language is russian and i'm not
i think this uh between that and the
character limit they're a little bit
hard to
interpret so i'm going to read all three
of them and see if we can get something
juicy out of this okay um on brain and
culture
coevolution markov proposed that brain
size decrease in homo sapiens is linked
to culture emerging and helping to
survive
well smartphones outsource of brain
activity press selection in that way
and actually that one is separate from
the next two so i think we can
to this one say um homo
is not experiencing a brain size
decrease i thought about this
okay there's one place where we do
relative to neanderthals there's like a
loss of a lobe and we don't know
um much about what it is but certainly
but of course
we're not using the paleontological
species concept right like neanderthals
didn't precede us we didn't all evolve
from neanderthals
people of european descent have a little
bit of neanderthal genealogy
in us um but um
but for the most part neanderthals is a
branch off of
the the homo sapiens lineage
and um really we see over you know
within mammals
an increase in brain size um to body
size ratio
within primates we see that accelerating
within apes we see that accelerating
and within the hominid lineage within
the oscillopithecine and homo lineage
um specifically we see brain size to
body size
increasing and specifically these ripple
cortex increasing relative to
the size of the rest of the brain but
that question was rephrased within
rather than in within which would be a
case
of a reduction that's the only one that
i know
of right i mean neanderthals a is a
different species and it's a branch
um so i don't know that we i think
there's still something interesting here
but i just wanted to make sure that we
like that we see
other than neanderthals appear not sure
about the additional lobe in
neanderthals i don't know this
yeah um because that would be a totally
new
i guess it would be a different lobe
within the cerebral cortex so without
the telomere
it's not a hemisphere just a particular
globe and we know
obviously because we don't have any
neanderthal brains to look at all we
know is
the volume um but
it is pretty likely that one of the
reasons that homo sapiens
out competed neanderthals was
plasticity and it may have had to do
with the degree i
have never believed that neanderthals
did not have language
they pretty clearly must have but they
probably
had reduced capacity to transmit
abstract ideas
using language and so um it
it is true that basically a sort of uh
exporting of certain functions to other
brains or other mechanisms
would potentially decrease the amount of
space necessary and there's intense
pressure to make the brain no bigger
than needed because big brains are
vulnerable
they're expensive to run and uh they're
expensive to build
so so yes uh that is likely
uh and i thought that i would uh
take this opportunity to give a
recommendation on a novel
uh which is william golding who is most
famous for lord of the flies
wrote a book called the inheritors in
which he imagines
life in a band of neanderthals and he
imagines them if i remember correctly
without language
we actually read it in a program i
taught with a linguist
it was her suggestion that we that we
turn this way because we've got noise on
our driveway now um
we it's really it's quite it's quite
excellent
and really gives some insight uh in a
narrative form to what it might have
been like to live
as an alternative form of hominid some
some tens of thousands of years ago
cool i don't remember he doesn't specify
when
anyway okay um so the next two questions
from the same
same person um i'll read them as they're
written let's
try to make sense of them here could you
please describe your opinion
how the propaganda could be handled
social media filter bubble youtube etc
assigns opinions to people critical
thinking is rare
also with regard to brain and talent um
is it nature versus nurture or
uh brain intelligence defines success
and the invisible inequality
that couldn't be changed and three uh
it's a great idea about poor communities
with a broken culture
how do you see the way out
all kinds of social and canine canine
chaos here
yeah um so i would just say
a few things one i believe
we are struggling and to some degree
successful at figuring out how to
navigate a world of garbage including
propaganda
propaganda being intentional garbage
rather than noise
um but then in some sense that's a good
definition
yeah in some sense you know idw and all
of the things that
look and function like it you know
long-form podcasting
and the like are experiments in this and
in some sense
you know i don't want to reduce it too
much because
you know the magic is what it is for
whatever reason you're tuning in but
why are you tuning in right you're
hearing people talk
you know off the cuff about things those
people have
some level of expertise they have some
track record at being able to
you know guess what's interesting what's
important what can be discounted
able to look at a story and say actually
that claim is suspect and here's why i
think so
but you know it's really odd that you
would want to tune into
a conversation between people that
you've
never met on the other hand it turns out
that really the game is about you are
terrible at self-promotion
i must say so bad but it's actually part
of why people trust me
i just suck at it why are you here yeah
well why are you here but here's the
thing if you're if the question
really was look all there was is
conversations between people
and your ability to figure out what's
true is a question
of how good is your discernment and
which conversations
tend to be at least more informative
than they are misleading maybe most
conversations are more misleading than
informative so
there's some small subset of
conversations that are more informative
than misleading and then the question is
well
which one's a good return on your
investment of time
and thought energy right and so you know
there's some pinnacle of that
and then there's things below it and
then there's the question about
it's not an absolute value because
there's a question of what's important
to you
right it may be you know there may be
discussions that are really high quality
on topics that wouldn't be that much
used to you to know about
so anyway you're you're choosing to
invest your time
tuning into a conversation and the who
you tune into
because of how it plays out you know i
mean for me what i would do is
i tune into a conversation and then i
see
how it tracks what later turns out to be
judgeable as to whether or not it was
accurate and important
and see which conversations proved to be
predictive you know it's sort of loosely
scientific
so what's the solution to propaganda is
a system in which those conversations
that tend to be insightful about
important things
over time the conversations that prove
out are the ones that peop more people
tune into and then what does that
develop into
its collective sense making right and
this is part of why
the joe rogan sam harris universe
of podcasts is the
important and and controversial force
that it is is that in some sense it has
demonstrated
that even though it makes mistakes just
like everybody else
over time it turns out that people who
tune into those discussions
have ended up enlightened relative to
those who have tuned into the mainstream
stuff
which is really low quality and um
anyway
so something like that would be the
answer
good trim that was the next part but i
think you
yeah um yeah one more thing on the brain
talent nature versus nurture thing
the thing to know about humans is you've
been told nature versus nurture is a bad
dichotomy and it is
because it's always both however what
you haven't been told
is that human beings are the most
nurture based creature of
any that has ever existed on planet
earth we are not a blank slate
but we are the blankest slate and so
that fact of us being the blanket slate
and the meaning
why would the creature that dominates
every uh productive habitat on earth
also be the most nurture based that's
the key to understanding what human
beings
um are and uh
so in any case um it's not nature versus
nurture but
these talents are housed in a brain that
is
largely un or i don't want to say
largely unwired but more unwired at
birth
than any other and therefore the chance
for us to democratize
tools and for us to increase
our capacity to think is the greatest of
any creature because
we have the the blankest canvas on which
to paint
okay this next one uh is from someone
i'm gonna read it
um if i can't get back on the jiu jitsu
mats i will kill myself
it's my therapy i need it i am against
the lockdown i'm getting to the edge
here i can't hold on to my sanity
i need jiu jitsu to live that's my
medicine um
i i hear you and
um you're not alone in feeling that way
and that is
not a resolution to the problem that you
are having there are
many people who have found ways to deal
with the modern condition which is so
unlike any condition that humans have
dealt with before
that requires some modernity such that
exactly the thing that you have clued
together
to deal with modernity can itself be
taken away
by modern decision making and that is
awful and i don't know what the answer
to address that particular conundrum
that many people find themselves
in is well this is a very jarring
question because of course um
the idea of self-harm here is both easy
to understand
and such a dire and one-way choice
um i would say there has got to be
and this is something we've been on
about for months now
our failure to understand that there are
things
idiosyncrasies about our situation that
work against us
and there are others that work for us
and we are not leveraging the ones that
work
for us so that we can afford to borrow
more where
we are more constrained and so i would
say look
surely surely there is a way to
reformulate what you're doing
in jiu-jitsu so it can be done outside
during the day uv light maybe it has to
be
done with a mask i don't know frankly if
that's possible impossible
imaginable not imaginable i know i don't
feel very good about riding a bike with
a mask but i see people doing it
yeah so i know it's not impossible but
but is there a way
or you know could you have a jiu jitsu
collective
of people who um are hyper vigilant
about protecting themselves get a test
be hyper vigilant about isolation
and participate in a community a jiu
jitsu community that has very low risk
of carrying any kovid through the door
right and then could you then do it
outside something like that when
you know presuming you're in the
northern hemisphere which most people
are
at the point that it is no longer sunny
out you know
i mentioned a long time ago i haven't
heard anybody respond to it but
you know couldn't we have light bulbs
that put out uv
light when nobody's in the room right
couldn't we have like self-purifying
rooms
in which you know these risks were
reduced yeah can what can you do with
air circulation
right the way we circulate air currently
may make things worse but
really there is a way to circulate air
that would make them
better and you know look you're spelling
out just how
dire the problem actually is it's not an
aesthetic
question this is something built into
you your core
and you need it and we all have those
things and i mean that's that's so key
it's not an aesthetic question and
depending on which side you know which
camp you've decided which tribe you've
decided to belong to
you will have become accustomed to being
mocked by the other side for something
on the basis that this is just your
preference and this is just an aesthetic
thing
that may not be the word that they use
but it's um it's dehumanizing and
disrespectful
and downright mean and potentially
dangerous
that um most of us who are functional
have one or a few things that we
actually
really need to do in order to continue
to feel like
full human beings and for almost
everyone
at least one of those things is being
seriously curtailed by this series of
events that we're living through right
now
and that is it makes it no easier at all
for the individual to know that the
entire world
to some degree is going through
something similar but it's true
um yeah i think the last thing to say is
you know
heather set it up front you're not alone
frederick hang in there
assume that a laboratory used the gila
henrietta lacks
cells to study or engineer the virus
could this explain the disproportionate
impact on the black community
[Music]
not just that it could explain
the tendency which now seems to be
eroding for it to infect
older people rather than younger people
it could
uh have all kinds of of impacts and
you know this is a two-piece she wasn't
old i think
no but she was certainly well into
adulthood yeah she was 60s maybe yeah so
initially this was much less prevalent
in kids even though kids are much more
likely to
um snot all over each other and you know
that kind of thing
yes they are right so i can't remember
though as the last time that happened
between adults
no it's it's not as common to be
sure um but you know my point would be
look
on the one hand if this is a lab escape
which is ever more likely it has all
kinds of implications for what it's
programmed to do and what it is
incompetent at doing and the more
frivolously we treat this
the more tricks that it cannot currently
do that it will learn and i worry that
one of these things
is um that the tendency for it to infect
children at a greater rate which we are
now seeing these reports
that this is a trick that it has now
learned on top of what it knew when it
jumped oceans and we should treat this
stuff much more carefully
it probably doesn't transmit very much
outdoors during the day at this point
we should preserve that because it's a
godsend right
we should preserve that at all costs the
last thing you want is for it to figure
out how to transmit itself outdoors so
there's nowhere to go at the moment
we have a vast landscape of places
outdoors that you can go in reasonable
safety
and that's uh to be cherished
that's right uh what what time are we at
zach
okay uh that's sort of what i was
worried about you're gonna say let's do
two more here and then
skip to the next livestream okay
are you familiar with the research
pointing toward memory engrams being
carried by rna
i imagine this must be a mechanism for
transfer of fitness needs
it must also impact society and its
evolution with each generation
potentially reinforcing that memorial
lineage
might maybe tendency of cultural
insanity skips generations
like schizophrenia um i
want to proceed with great caution about
the idea of engrams being transmitted
in or on the genome um
yeah i've seen just a very little bit of
this in the past and
um it did not strike me as particularly
compelling but i have not run into it
lately so i have very little
that said lots of things do travel on
the genome that transmit things between
generations and this says unfortunately
because it is the most interesting and
uh
surprising result in molecular
epigenetics
it has sucked up a lot of the attention
which has robbed
epigenetics of at least in the popular
conception
uh its proper understanding as the key
to creating an organism from a genome
that is shared between all of its cells
so anyway i'll just put a placeholder
there we can talk more about that some
other time
all right okay one more question here uh
and then we'll
go to the next live stream i'm one of
those conservatives you mentioned in the
beginning
question how much do you think
demographic change and diversity
plays a part in the issues we are seeing
today
um i'm not sure i understand the
question
well uh i think what it part of what it
can be
is uh is their uh legitimate grievance
that has been
uh at a level in the population has been
low enough that people weren't voicing
it
and as as america at least becomes even
less homogeneous than it
was which you know it never was all
white
but um but white people certainly had
the vast majority of the power
for for a long time um as
as it becomes less so does that change
uh what's possible in the sort of policy
change
and activism realms that's how i read
the question it's certainly a
demographic
tipping point um part of the problem is
that not only is there a tipping point
that is to say people who have
been or have felt disempowered or
suddenly recognizing that their numbers
carry potential political power if they
will wield it but
their tendency to do so along something
like racial lines
then causes people who have largely
forgotten about their interest to pursue
well-being along racial lines it's going
to drive them into doing so
so i've called this the speak of the
devil problem where
by accusing civilization of being white
supremacists where it isn't
you will cause white supremacy to emerge
because
whites will be forced to look at their
interests as a racial group because
they're being challenged as a racial
group so that's a very dangerous
property and we ought to be
incredibly cautious about it um
yeah all right let's get through as many
of these
in this hour super chat as we can can
you stop making such an amazing podcast
so often it's too good to skip an
episode but you stream faster than i can
watch
anyway thanks deal we will yeah but we
don't want you taking the hit now
we probably will uh roll back to once a
week at some point
um but at the moment at the moment this
is working at the moment we're going to
cut back to once every half week
good wow we do need that crickets
cricket
yeah sound effect yes thank you both for
what you do i'm sorry this is cheating i
gave as much money as i could
sent brought a relevant advice in korea
on his patreon it was too long for chat
any advice is appreciated zack if you
would just highlight that
we'll try to we'll see if we can shorten
it and read it at the top of the hour
next time
it's yeah what i've got highlighted here
34.
um why have doorda dordik
dordik and nudge people nope that's not
what that says at all no
why have dutch and nordic people become
so tall in recent times
apart from sexual selection mechanisms
are there advantages to height like
having more skin surface to make vitamin
d and high latitudes thanks
wow so the final part of that like
having more skin service to make vitamin
d and high latitudes
of course goes exactly opposite the
usual explanation for why
uh historically ancestrally uh high
latitude people
tend to be more sphere-like because the
closer you are to sphere
the lower you basically lower your
surface area to volume ratio and so you
lose heat less
um less quickly so um while i
i like that as a hypothesis it
definitely does
remind me of the kind of sort of
adaptive arm waving
that people in our field are often
accused of doing
right um i think it's not going to be
that because um
obviously becoming taller um and and
typically lean they're increasing their
serious volume ratio making them more
likely to um
lose extremities to frostbite or just
die of hypothermia more generally so
they're
so you know is it is it just sexual
selection is
it warrior-ness what what else might
explain the height and i'm going to go
ahead and call them the
uh dortec and nudge people because
that's how i misread it the first time
i have uh i have not seen this question
before but i have what i would call a
deep
out of the money hypothesis here which
means
very unlikely to be true but big payoff
if it is
all right do it um one of the things you
will notice one of the things i always
relearn when it becomes biking season
again after
you know after winter yes
is that i have forgotten how to dress
for it and actually the same thing maybe
more importantly
in reverse as uh bad weather sets in
there's a tendency to try to dress for
the weather as you leave your door
but if you dress for the weather and you
leave your door then you quickly
overheat given
whatever you're wearing to uh keep you
to dry and you and you mock me for this
okay at the top of the hill you're gonna
have to take off your scarf
at the top of the next until you're
gonna take off your jacket but here's my
point anyway go on
in the summer you're closer to naked
right
and the thing is you have a
fantastically complex system
for maintaining a very narrow range of
body temperatures
that involves capillary beds that can
open up to
get rid of heat really quickly or close
down to preserve heat right
and it's all happening all over your
body with different extremities that
function as radiators and it's a very
complex system
that you don't need to know anything
about and it works beautifully up to a
point
right there's a point at which you're
creating more heat than you can shed
and then you're at risk of heat stroke
but that point is pretty freaking far
off
right you can do a lot of stuff on a
very hot day and not get heat stroke
so if you've got some basic level of
fitness
yeah with with some basic level of
fitness
your body can keep you in that range and
what you don't appreciate
is how active a process that is of
shedding heat and preserving heat in
order to maintain
ranges that are really tightly
constrained because they have to be
because every enzyme in your body is
actually dependent on that range in
order to even work very well so
total collapse comes if you get too far
outside of this range and you've got
this automatic system that does it
beautifully
you put on a sweater worse
a jacket worse a jacket that doesn't
breathe and the point is that internal
system is still trying to do what it
does
but it runs into something it can't
control right so in other words
it'll you know if you start to heat up
in your jacket as you're biking
in you know uh in december
your uh body will react as if you're
naked and it will
flush your radiators your back and your
limbs with um with blood in order to
shed the heat that you're building up
but if anything it's shedding inside of
the jacket isn't really
shed it builds up right the way warmth
does in a
in a wetsuit and so the point is you
very quickly get to a point where you're
just building up heat and you can't shed
it because something you've put between
you and the world is interfering with
the natural processes
that allow this thing um to
work and so deep out of the money
hypothesis
why are they so tall in scandinavia
right so here's the question what if you
had an ancestral
population that instead of being in the
position of facing winter and having to
relearn how to dress for it
was actually kind of built for this
process where it did
wear these external things and somehow
the internal bodily processes
have to be able to shed heat through
whatever it is that you tend to wear
over your surface and that that process
has been coordinated and so
we tend to think people who live closer
to the arctic circle
will be rounder in order to preserve
heat because losing heat is the thing
that threatens them
but if you are a more technological
population where you are operating
very regularly in these circumstances
where you are interfering with
uh freezing by putting layers over you
you might actually want an
increased capacity to radiate basically
you know the person isn't the system the
person plus
the clothing plus the food used to fuel
the organism is the system
and that in fact you would get a body
form that looked more like a kenyan
um because the sum total of the system
would work better again very unlikely
this is true so the hypothesis
is scandinavians are tall because
clothing and that's you know that's a
bit of a
caricature but that's it that's it in a
nutshell
but the prediction then is uh for
uh nearby but more southerly populations
say
germans and french and such who aren't
as tall on average that
at the same moment when the
scandinavians were becoming tall
that the more southerly populations had
less clothing technology
um i think the way i would say it
actually the comparison
population i would do is something like
arctic people like inuits versus
i'd rather i'd rather it be shared you
know
most recent common ancestor that's
really close yeah
well any of these things work to test it
but the real question i would say
is the combination of
agriculture that
releases the limit on food supply in
other words
for people who are hunting marine
mammals for example there's a
limit on the amount of calories that can
be
acquired and so the preservation of heat
is the higher priority
and i'm wondering if agriculture
in so because obviously you know arctic
peoples have
clothing that preserves heat um but
the question is you've got several
parameters in the model how expensive
is the material that you burn to make
heat that is to say how scarce is food
you've got a question about what kinds
of
technology you have for preserving heat
technologically that is to say clothing
and then you've got what is your
internal structure going to
tend to radiate versus preserve and how
much flexibility is and i guess what i'm
arguing is
you get the flexibility from the lanky
body body form
if you have the clothing and the food
supply to take to
suffer the cost so i'd like to see both
comparisons um and we'd have to know
when we're comparing two but both you
know same latitude
uh different different continents and
most recent common ancestor that's at
least
at least 15 probably close to 25 000
years ago
between scandinavians and uh inuit say
yep um well i know it might be closer
actually because they were a later
movement into the new world um than the
original americans
um and then i but i'd be even more
interested to see the comparison
um within european populations
because it does seem that at least we
all have in our head that scandinavians
are
um taller than the sort of central
western europeans
and uh i i don't i don't see this quite
working out but it's about it's about
clothing and it's about
um lack of caloric deficit so that's the
other
you're the addition to the hypothesis
not just clothing it's lack of caloric
deficit
um and with that with regard to compared
to the arctic i think
what was uh implied in what you said is
basically that the
jet stream renders the same latitude in
europe
much more fruitful with regard to the
possibility of agriculture
uh at least you know it's a very short
growing season but there is a growing
season whereas there's nothing you know
the inuit are not
eating any plant-based food really
except what they pull from the sea
right i'm sure there's a certain amount
of very very gathering
stuff but they're not i don't think
they're engaging in agriculture yeah
um so i just say final thing
is the way to test hypotheses like this
are to look for transitions
in space or in time that would tell you
you know the height that you're looking
for that's surprising where does it stop
and is the transition at that place
about
how food is produced what clothing is
worn that sort of thing
yeah and you can see the same thing as
time progresses
okay the next uh question seems to be
about woodchucks
specifically how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck's
ancestors had not recit
oh boy let me start again how much wood
would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck's
ancestors had not resided with it in an
environment where chucking wood would
have converted an increased propensity
to thrive and leave offspring
zero that's the militant moderate again
i think that
am i right that i understood that and
that the answer is i was reading and i
did not understand the question
wow right zero and i believe such a
woodchuck would chuck no wood
and woodchucks do chuck no wood
because woodchucks are marmots yeah
yep so but beaver doesn't it doesn't
work
that's right that's what it means right
so is it possible that beaver that
woodchucks
and beavers were ever the same i mean i
don't mean
genetically i mean these are not sirens
no no that's not what i mean
photogenically i mean like did did the
first person who wrote that did they
think that a beaver was a woodchuck oh
is this like
uh the way in jamaica pear means avocado
yeah and uh and that
is rat bat bat means moth and rat bat
means bat
yeah yeah like that yeah it's it's quite
possible because yeah
beavers do a certain amount of uh
talking of wood yes whatever trucking
they absolutely do i mean i think we can
all agree that beavers check would but
apparently woodchucks do not being
cyards which is squirrels
and squirrels chuck no wood they chuck
no wood yeah yeah
and they hold no truck with those that
do they hold no truck with those that
chuck
exactly yeah yeah all right
so tired of listening to you people um
okay we're gonna do
five more okay in 2009
h1n1 infected roughly one billion people
and then became part of the annual flu
season
why didn't it mutate the way you warned
sars cove too well
i'm not sure what you think we've said
about what we
think about how cyrus cove two will
mutate
we have said that it may well mutate in
a number of ways but i'm not sure do you
can you figure out from this
which of the things we have said so i
there's not enough here i'm wondering if
h1n1
shows up in this comparison because
of the uh now well
established fact of lab escape i believe
it's h1n1
that escaped we don't know where from oh
i didn't know that
70 i'm now just remembering off the top
my head but i think
78 either china or russia is thought to
be the source
um is it 78 the year or is that just a
number inserted i'm hoping i'm not stuck
about any of these facts but uh yes
there is a famous
now established lab leak um
and so the question so if that is the
comparison and that is the reason that
you are delivering h1n1 here for us to
compare sars cove 2
to then i would say the reason that we
don't expect the same thing
is that what you had in the case of that
lab leak
was a natural virus
i believe not one that had gone through
serial passaging
serial passaging in this case the reason
that it looms large for us
is they would have trained the virus on
particular idiosyncrasies of the
laboratory process
and the tissue or the creatures that the
serial passaging took place
in and therefore that would have drawn
the virus out to somewhere
and then we would expect it to revert
back
um to something else or not back but at
least it would adapt to the human
population as it finds it it would
discover new opportunities
etc but no we expect
all viruses to evolve over time
and in fact one of the reasons that flu
is seasonal is that the rate of
evolution is high enough
that immunity doesn't persist and so we
basically stuck with these things over
long periods of time because
the rate of change is sufficient to
erase
the protectiveness of memory cells over
time
all right uh hi in the light of
orthotropic discussion does it seem like
a good idea to chew
chewing gum constantly for part of the
day perhaps several hours sugarless
natural
the sap resin is probably harder load
teeth without wearing them
so this is one of the things that mike
mew specifically recommends
and we went ahead and bought some
some sugar-free natural um
tree gum gum that's flavored
interestingly i guess
what it's called monica chiclay tree
simply zac says it's called simply gum
and it is indeed from the monaco
chiclay tree from which the brand name
chiclets comes
not that chiclets is any more from that
tree or they originally originally was
um i would say i certainly go natural
over
any of the synthetic sweetener stuff i
would say the disappointing thing
about the gum is that it is not um
robust enough to constitute the best
exercise in other words
it's not generated with exercise in mind
and so
well he wants so mike mew recommends i
don't know how big the sticks of gum are
in england but he recommends putting 10
pieces in your mouth at a time and
making what he calls a really large
bolus that you move around your mouth
really actively
well i'll just point out that britain
being an island there's a limit to how
big the sticks could be
this is a really terrible point
truly terrible point um but anyway i
would say look i actually think somebody
ought to formulate a gum
specifically for the purpose of the
exercises that
uh that mike is pointing to and the fact
is
your sense that gum should be sweet
probably that's unnecessary
my guess is gun gum could be uh
pleasant if it was not sweet
in other words mint might be enough
sweet it's not necessary to go with mint
even if we sort of associate the two
and that a gum that was formulated to
resist
better would be useful
so anyway there's a lot that could be
done to make it better but i would also
point out it is not a simple matter of
chewing gum i don't believe
i think you know he's got specific mike
mio's specific ways that he wants you
sort of moving it around your mouth and
then uh
flattening it against the brief your
mouth pulverizing it against the roof of
your mouth
to strengthen your tongue and all of
these things so i suspect that this is
super useful but we haven't found that i
admit i mean you you and the kids have
actually been doing it more i think i
tried it twice i'm sorry like
i gave up yeah i just don't like chewing
gum i never did
yeah maybe you could get someone to do
it for you oh that's good yeah let's
outsource the work that we need to do
for ourselves this is exactly how we got
here
yes yes it is okay uh
heather i know you're seeking art free
from awoke lens yes i
am my girlfriend's young adult novel
introduces
enlightenment values through a plot
device of learning to cast magic within
a contemporary fantasy world
please note dual nature by brenna r
singman
will do thank you cool
given that trade-offs exist six-week
lockdown kills the economy
isn't the better way out of the virus a
to protect risk groups and b
let others work economy is vital for
finding cure
so um this
i think there's something here i don't
think it's quite quite this simple
um but maybe you think we can talk a
little bit about our conversation that
we had with our former students
uh when they came by yeah so we've got a
couple of former students and a friend
of theirs who also
went to evergreen all of them scientists
um and sort of
active in the rationality community who
came by on their way
through through portland we sat on our
deck social distancing
and talked for a while uh and uh one of
the things
that one of them is not going to use
their names because we haven't asked
them in advance
but said was that you know clearly what
we need
is track and trace um you know
abundant rapid turnaround testing uh
with track and trace in place uh such
that
uh you can immediately isolate people
who are sick and one of the things you
asked him
was don't don't you also need that in
combination with a lockdown
and he said no he said actually i don't
think it's necessary if you really had
sufficient tests that were a
reliable and you know really the thing
that no one is talking about that is
obviously super important and this to
your anecdote in the first hour today
um that has a super fast turnaround best
if it's basically instantaneous best if
they were so abundant
and so inexpensive that we could all be
doing it every day when we got up
and with that then you have track and
trace and that would free up the vast
majority of us to go about
our business and to to do normal things
and get the economy
back to normal including the scientists
who
ought to be doing things like working on
a vaccine against this virus
so i would say plausibly
such a thing could work without a
severe brief lockdown the likelihood of
getting
the parameters to the place they need to
be in order that you don't need that
severe brief lockdown is low so probably
you need to combine these things
but the other thing we need which may
ironically be the hardest of these to
accomplish
is that we need to get on the same
freaking page about this
you can't have half the population
imagining that this is a hoax or it's
not very dangerous
or whatever the thing is you can't say
it very next question from the same
person addresses this let me just
interrupt with that and let you riff
then because real lockdown isn't doable
people aren't robots to obey 100 orders
plus you need to manage multiple risks
including guests from other causes
uh and boosting immunity could help
check taib gallo i'm not sure what that
reference is but
go on so anyway the point is simply this
is
it's not even that we all need to get on
the same page
for us we are actually putting the world
in jeopardy to the extent that we are
half of us are going to opt out of
whatever measures it is because
we believe we're being taken advantage
of by globalists or whatever
that thing is going to prevent us from
managing this virus
that's going to leave the virus in the
wild give it a lot more
landscape in which to experiment with
new tricks so it's going to turn into
something new on our watch
and what initially may have been
a you know failure of a laboratory
involved in an international effort to
study these things
is going to be you know and then is
spread by um
bad behavior on the part of the chinese
communist party
is then going to be our responsibility
for having allowed it to
equilibrate and experiment and learn new
tricks on
our watch and we are going to be
quarantined by the rest of the world
which is certainly not good for us
so all of these things suggest
no matter what you think the reality of
this virus is
you should participate with the rest of
us in
driving it as close to zero as we can
get
through being very careful with each
other and it is somehow this
loss of empathy and this belief
that people who disagree with you are
inherently wrong
and stupid and suckers and all the
things that people tend to think
those who disagree with them are this is
not the case we know we have a virus it
is real i assure you
we know people who have it right it's
serious
we know that it does harm and that these
harms are unpredictable
long-lasting life-altering harms
that's enough we should be very serious
about taking care of it as quickly as
possible
and you know take it from the
evolutionary biologists who have been on
about this for months
you don't want to give it room to
experiment
that's where we undo well-being is we
give it room to experiment
and then by the time we get savvy about
this thing it's too late
because it has now become endemic to
humans right
that's not where we want to be and we
still have the potential to prevent that
from happening
but not if we're in different places
about it
i think that's a good place to stop all
right well
yeah good well again we have um
we have patreons where you can uh find
access to
discord server and uh darkhorse
membership where you have access to a
private q a every month
and there's a link to there's a clips
channel where you will find uh clips
from today's episode and past ones
and unity 2020s first campfire is
tomorrow night
it sounds like at 6 00 p.m pacific 9 pm
eastern what
else um thank you
all yes thank you so much for your
support and uh
i don't know like subscribe comment
uh challenge shake your fist at the
screen if need be but we won't see it
um that's not the way this works we'll
feel it
all right until next time folks
be well
[Music]
[Music]
you